today I'm delighted to introduce us our final guest speaker um Bean Kim um being Kim is a staff research scientist at Google brain if you're really into googleology you know those funny words the beginning like staff sort of says how senior you are um and that means that being's a good research scientist um um so uh I I discovered at lunch today that bean started out um studying mechanical engineering at Seoul national university but she moved on to uh I don't know if it's better
things or not but she moved on to computer science and did a PhD um at MIT and there she started working on the interpretability and explainability of machine learning models um I think she'll be talking about some different parts of her work but a theme that she's had in some of her recent work that I find especially appealing as an NLP person is the idea that we should be using higher level human interpretable languages for communication between people and machines and so welcome Bean looking
forward to your talk um and go for it thank you thank you thanks for having me it's honored to be here it's the rainiest Stanford I've ever seen last night I got here last night but then I'm I live in Seattle so this is pretty common so I still was able to see the blue sky today I was like this works I really like it here so today I'm going to share some of my dreams chasing my dreams to communicate with machines so if you're in this class you probably agree you don't have to that large
language models and generated models are pretty cool they're impressive but you may also agree that they're a little bit frightening not just because they're impressive they're doing really good job but also we're not quite sure where we're going with this technology in 10 years out will we look back and say that technology was net positive or we will say ah that was catastrophic we didn't know that that would happen and ultimately what I would like to do or maybe hopefully what we all want to
do is to have this technology benefit us humans I know in 10 years time or maybe well 20 years or earlier he's gonna ask me he's gonna be like Mom did you work on this AI stuff I watched some of your talks and did you know that how this will profoundly change our lives and what did you do about that and I have to answer that question and I really hope that I have some good things to say to him so my initial thought or an instill so or current thought is that if we want our ultimate goal to be benefit Humanity
why not directly optimize for it why wait so how can we benefit there's lots of different ways we can benefit but one way we can benefit is to treat this like a colleague you know a colleague who are really good at something it's called it's not perfect but it's good at something enough that you want to learn something from them one difference is though in this case is that this colleague is kind of weird this colleague might have very different values it might has very different
experiences in the world it may not care about surviving as much as we do maybe mortality isn't really a thing for this colleague so you have to navigate that in our conversation so what do you do when you first meet somebody there's someone so different what do you do you try to have a conversation to figure out what how do you do what you do how are you solving decades-old protein folding problem how are you so how are you beating the world gold champion so easily What It Seems are you using the same language the
science knowledge the language that we use atoms molecules or do you think about the world in a very different way and more importantly how can we work together I have a one area that I really want to talk to and it's alphago so alphago beat world of gold Champion Isador in 2016. Isidore is from South Korea I'm from South Korea I watched every single batch it was such a big deal in South Korea and worldwide I hope and in one of the matches alphago played this move called move 37. how many
people watched alphago match matches and how many people remember move 37. yeah a few people right and I remember the nine Don commentator who's been like talking a lot throughout the matches suddenly got really quiet and he said hmm that's a very strange move and I knew then that something really interesting has just happened in from my eyes that this is gonna change something the South Fargo has made something that we're gonna remember forever and sure enough this move turned around the game
for alphago and leading Alpha go to win one of the matches so go players today continue to analyze this move and still discuss people talk about this is not the move a human would Phantom so the question is how did alphago know this is a good move my dream is to learn something new by communicating the machine with machines and having a conversation and such that Humanity will gain some new angle to our important problems like medicine and Science and many others and this is not just about discovering
new things if you think about reward hacking you have to have a meaningful conversation with somebody to truly figure out what their true goal is so in a way solving this problem is a superset of solving AI safety too so how do we have this conversation conversation assumes that we share some common vocabulary between uh that that exchange to exchange meaning and ultimately the knowledge and naturally a representation plays a key role in this conversation on the left and we can visualize this on the left we say what
this is a representational space of what humans know on the right what machines know here in left Circle there will be something like this dog is Fluffy and you know what that means because we all share somewhat similar recovery but on the right we have something like move 37 where we humans yet to have a representation for so how do we have this conversation our representation space needs overlap and the more overlap we have the better conversation we're going to have humans are all good at learning new things like
here everyone is learning something new so we can expand what we know by learning new Concepts and vocabularies and doing so I believe will help us to build machines that can better align with our values and our goals so this is the talk that I gave if you're curious about some of the work we're doing towards this direction I highly recommend it's a YouTube video I clear keen on half an hour you can fast uh do a best feed but today I'm going to talk more about my hopes and dreams
and hopefully at the end of the day your hopes and dream is there so first of all I'm just gonna set the expectation so at the end of this talk we still don't know how the move 37 is made okay sorry that's going to take a while in fact the first part of this talk is going to be about how we move backwards in this progress in in terms of making this progress in our journey and still very very small portion of our entire Journey towards understanding move 37 and of course this journey wouldn't be
like a singular path there will be lots of different branches coming in core ideas like Transformer helped many domains across they will be similar here so I'm going to talk in the part two some of our work on understanding emerging behaviors in reinforcement learning and all the techniques that I'm going to talk about is going to be in principle applicable to NLP so coming back to our move our dreams and hopes and dreams 37. so let's first think about how we might realize this dream
and taking a step back we have to ask do we have tools to First estimate what even machines know there has been many development in machine learning last decade now to develop tools to understand and estimate this purple circle so is that accurate unfortunately many Recent research showed that there's a huge gap between What machines actually know and what we think the machines know and identifying and bridging this Gap is important because these tools will form basis for understanding that move 37.
so what are these tools how many people familiar with sale in cmaps a lot but you don't have to explain what it is so saliency map is one of the popular interpretability methods for Simplicity let's say an imagenet you have an image like this you have a bird the explanation is going to take a form of the same image but where each pixel is numb with associated with a number that is supposed to imply some importance of that pixel for prediction of this image and one definition of that importance is
that that number indicates how the function looked like around this pixel so for example if I have a pixel I XJ maybe around XJ the function moves up like the yellow curve or function is flat or a function is going down like the green curve and so if it's flat like a like a blue curve or red curve maybe that feature is irrelevant to predicting bird maybe it's going up then it's maybe more important because the value of X increases and the function value goes up function value here like a prediction value
so let's think about what are the few ways why this Gap might exist there are fewer is not exhaustive they're overlap a little bit but helpful for us to think about maybe assumptions are wrong so this alien again these machines that we train Works in a completely different perhaps completely different representational space very different experiences about the world so assuming that it sees the world that we do just like we do like having the gesture phenomenon there's few dots humans are
have tendency to connect them maybe machines have the two maybe not so maybe our assumptions about these machines were wrong maybe our expectations are mismatched we thought it was doing X but it was actually doing y or maybe it's beyond us maybe it's showing something superhuman that humans just can't understand I'm going to take a deeper into one of uh some of these our work this is more recent work so again coming back to the earlier story about Salient cement we're going
to play with some of these methods now uh in 2018 we stumbled upon this phenomenon that was quite shocking which was that we were actually trying to write some different people again people of Christians here but we were testing something and we realized that train Network and untrained network has the same very similar as alien cmap in other words random prediction and meaningful prediction were giving me the same explanation so that was puzzling we thought we had a bug but it turned out we didn't it
actually is in this thing indistinguishable qualitatively and quantitatively so that was shocking but then we wondered maybe this one-off case maybe it still works somehow in practice so we tested that in a follow-up paper okay what if the model had an error one of these errors maybe it has a labeling error maybe it has a spheres correlation maybe that had Auto distribution at test time if we intentionally insert these bugs can explanation tell us that there's something wrong with the model
it turns out that that's also not quite true you might think that oh maybe superior's correlation another follow-up work also showed that this is also not the case so we were disappointed but then still we say you know maybe there is a there's no theoretical proof of this maybe this is again a lab setting test we had grad students to test this system maybe there's still some hope so this is more recent work where we theoretically prove that some of these methods very popular methods cannot do
better than random so I'm going to talk a little a little bit about that I'm missing one person oh I'm missing Tang way in the author list I just realized this is also work with pangwei so let's first talk about our expectation what is our expectation about this tool now the original paper that developed this method IG and Shop talks about how IG can be used for accounting the contributions of each feature so what that means is that when the Tool assigns zero attribution to a pixel
we're gonna say okay well pixel is on used by the function and that means that F will be insensitive if I perturb this X and in fact this is how it's been used it in practice this is a paper published in nature they use the shop to figure out the eligibility criteria in a medical trial what we show in this work is that none of these inferences that seemed pretty natural were true and in fact just because popular attribution methods tell you anything about it attribution is X you cannot conclude anything about the actual Model
Behavior so how does that work how many people here do Theory proof or few great I'll tell you I I learned about Theory proving from this project as well so I'll tell you like the way that that we pursued this particular work is that first think about this problem and we're going to formulate into some other problem that we know how to solve so in this case we formulate this as hypothesis testing because once you formulate in the hypothesis testing yes or no there are lots of tools in
statistics you can use to prove this so what is hypothesis the hypothesis is that I'm a user I got an attribution value from one of these tools and I have a mental model of ah this feature is important or maybe not important then the hypothesis is that whether that's true or not and what we showed is that given whatever hypothesis you may have we can you cannot do better than random guessing invalidating or invalidating this hypothesis testing and that means yes it's sometimes it's
right but you don't do hypothesis testing if you cannot validate yes or no you just don't because like what's the point of doing it if you just don't know if it's as good as random guessing right and the result is that yes for for this for this graph it's just a visualization of our results if you plot true negative and true positive and line is random guessing because this is the worst method that's the best method all the equal distance is this line methods that we know shop in IG all all falls under
this line of random guessing that's bad news but maybe maybe this still works in practice for some reason maybe there were some assumptions that we had that didn't quite meet in the practice so does this phenomenal hold in practice the answer is yes we did we now have more image graphs and more bigger models but here we test two concrete and tasks that people care about in interpretability or use these methods to do recourse or spiritual correlation so recourse for those are not familiaries
you're getting a loan and you wonder whether if I'm older I would have a high chance of getting a loan so I tweak this one feature and see if my value goes up or down very reasonable task have people do all the time pretty significant implications socially so for two of these concrete and tasks both of them boil down to this hypothesis testing framework that I talked about they're all around the random guessing line over worse than random guessing so you might say oh no this is not good
A lot of people are using these tools what do we do we have very simple idea about this so people like developing complex tools and I really hope you're not one of those people because a lot of times simple methods work who comes Razer but also simple methods are elegant there's a reason perhaps a lot of times why they work they're simple that you can understand them they make sense so let's try that idea here so again your goal is to estimate a function shape what do you do well the simplest thing you do is you
have a point of interest you sample around that point and evaluate the function around that point if it goes up maybe functions going up if it goes down maybe functions coming down right so that's the simplest way you can kind of brute force it but then the question is how many samples do we need so here this is the equation that you're boosting you're lifting this line upwards that way by adding that additional term uh it's proportional to number of samples the more samples you have the
better estimation you have makes sense and differences in output how much resolution do you care do you care point zero point one to point point one to point two or do you only care zero slope to like slope one that's resolution that you care about and number of features of course so if you worry about making some conclusion based on function shape sample easy so can we infer the Model Behavior using this popular methods the answer is no and this holds both theory and practice we're currently working on even bigger
models to to show just like again you know again empirical evidence that yes it just really doesn't work please you know think of think twice and three times before using these methods and also a model dependent sample complexity if your function is kind of crazy of course you're going to need more samples so what is the definition of how do we characterize these functions and finally we haven't quite given up yet because these methods have a pretty good root in economics and and sharply
values and all that so maybe they're a lot narrower condition where these methods work and we believe such such condition does exist we just have to figure out when once we figure out what that condition is then in given function I can test it and say yes I can use shop here yes I can use IG here or no I can't that would be still very useful so ongoing work before I go to the next one any questions yes do the findings you have about the these models like does it only applied in computer-bit models or does it
applies any model and that has a function yeah very simple simple actually simplest proof that can show simply any function this holds any other questions it's wonderful yeah this relate to you a lot but like it's almost seems like for the last couple of years they're being at least dozens maybe hundreds of people writing to people through the Shipley values I mean it if you're guessed that most of that work that's invalid or that a lot of it might be okay because the the point of a
condition where it's all right right off of you being there so two answers to that question my hypothesis testing results shows that it's random right so maybe in the optimistic case optimistic case 50 of those papers you hit it and on the other side on the second note even if maybe shop wasn't perfect maybe it was kind of wrong but even if if it helped human at the end task whatever that might be Health doctors to be more efficient identifying bugs and whatnot and if they did the validation correctly
with the right control testing setup then I think it's good you know you figure it out somehow how to make this noisy tools together work with human interlude maybe and that's also good and I personally really like shop uh paper and I'm a I'm a good friend with Scott and I love all his work it's just that I think we need to narrow down our expectations so that our expectations are better aligned all right I'm going to talk about another word that's a kind of similar flavor
now it's an NLP so this is one of those papers just like the many other papers that that we we ended up writing one of those Serendipity paper so initially Peter came up as an intern and we thought we're gonna locate ethical knowledge in this large language models and then maybe we're gonna edit them to make them a little more ethical so that was a goal and then we thought oh the wrong paper from David Bowie and I also love David's work and let's use that so that's the start of this work
but then we start digging into and implementing the realm and like things didn't quite line up so we do like sanity check experiment after sanity check and we ended up writing completely different paper which I'm going to about to talk to you about so the this paper the Rome for those who are not familiar which I'm going into detail a little more detail in a bit is about editing a model so you first locate a knowledge in a in a model like the Space Needle is in Seattle that's a factor knowledge you locate them you
edit them because you can locate them you can mess with it to edit that fact that's like the whole promise of it in fact that's a lot of times how localization or editing methods were motivated in their literature but what we show is that this assumption is actually not true and to be quite honest with you like I still don't quite get why this is not related and I'll talk more about this because this is like a big question uh to us this is a pretty pretty um active work so substantial fraction of factual
knowledge is stored outside of layers that are identified as having no knowledge and you can you can you can see you can you will see this a little more detail in a bit in fact the correlation between where the location where where the facts are located and how well you will edit if we edit that location is completely correlated uncorrelated so they have nothing to do with each other so we thought well maybe it's the problem with the definition of editing what we mean by editing can mean a lot
of different things so let's think about different ways to edit a thing so we try a bunch of things with a little success we couldn't find an editing definition that actually relates really well with localization methods like in particular with ROM so let's talk a little bit about Rome how Rome Works super briefly there's a lot of details missed out on this side but roughly you will get the idea so Rome is Magneto 2022 uh they have what's called causal tracing algorithm and the
way it works is that you're going to run a model on this particular data set now counter effect data set that has this Tuple subject relation and object the space needle look is located in Seattle and so you're going to have a clean run of the Space Needle is in Seattle one time you stole every single module every single value activations and then in the second run which they call corrupted run you're going to add noise in those Space Needle is or or the space then then you're going to intervene at
every single one of those modules as if from by copying this module to the corrupted run so as if that particular model was never interrupted never a noise was never added to that module so it's a typical like intervention case where you pretend everything else being equal if I change just this one module what is the probability of having the right answer so in this case probability of the right answer Seattle given that I know it's the model and I intervened on it so at the end of the day you'll find
graph like that where each layer and each token has a score How likely it is if I intervene on that token in that layer how How likely is it that I will recover the right answer because if I recover right answer that's the model that's the module that's stored on knowledge really reasonable algorithm I couldn't find technical flow in this algorithm I quite like it actually so but but when we start looking at this using the same model that they use GPT gptj we realized that a lot of these
facts so so Rome uses just layer 6 to edit because that was the supposedly the best layer across this data set to add in most of the factual knowledge is stored in layer 6 and they showed uh editing success and whatnot but we realized the truth looks like the graph on the right so the red line is the layer 6 their extension paper called memet and it's multiple layers that's the Blue Line blue region the black bars are histogram of where the knowledge was actually peaked if you test every single layer and as you can
see not a lot of facts fall into that region so in fact every single fact has like different regions that where it peaked so layer six for a lot of facts weren't the best layer what the editing really worked it really works and we did we were able to duplicate that results so we thought what do we do to find this ethics ethical knowledge how do we find the best layer to edit so that's where we started but then we thought you know what take a step back we're going to actually do alternative check first to
make sure that tracing effect the the tracing effect is the localization rip implies better editing results and that's when everything started to falling apart so let's define some metrics first the edit success this is the rewrite score same score as roam paper used that's what we use and the tracing effect this is localization is probably you can beat the due to the slide so when we plotted the relation between tracing effect and rewrite score the local uh the the editing method Redline
applies the perfect correlation and that was our assumption that there will be perfectly correlated and which is why we do localization to begin with the actual line was yellow it's close to zero it's actually negative in this particular data set that is not even on correlated it's like anti-correlated and we didn't stop there we were like we were so puzzled we're gonna do this for every single layer and we're gonna find R square value so how much of the choice of layer versus the localization the tracing
effect explains the variance of successful edit if you're not familiar with r squared r squares like a think about it as an importance of a factor and it turns out that layer takes 94 dressing effect is zero zero one six and so we were really opposed that we were like scratching our head why is this true but it was true across layer we tried all sorts of different things we we tried different model we tried different data set it was all like roughly the case so we were at this point we contacted David and we start talking
about and and we resolve them they acknowledge that this is a phenomenon that that exists you know so apart from the layer the other way in which localization can happen is are you looking at the correct token is that the other like corresponding yeah yeah in this graph the token so the added benefit of the rest of the localization could only help you look at which is the correct subgroup token is that it yeah yeah and so looking at any of the software tokens it sort of finds what I should think of yeah yeah just
layer layer is the most biggest thing that's the only thing you should care if you care about editing layers in fact don't worry about localization at all it's extra wasted carbon uh climate effect yeah so that was that was our conclusion but then we thought you know maybe the particular definition of edit that they used in the room was was maybe different maybe maybe there's exists a definition of editing that correlates a lot better with localization because there must be I'm still puzzled why is this not
correlated so we tried a bunch of different definitions of edits you might inject an error you might uh you might invert reverse the tracing you might want to erase effect you might we might want to amplify the fact all these things like maybe one of these will work you did it so the craft that you're seeing down here is R square value for four different methods and this wasn't just the case for Roman memory it was also the case for fine tuning methods that you want to look at the difference
between blue and orange bar represents how much the tracing effect influenced our Square value of the tracing effect as you can see it's ignorable they're all the same you might feel the effect forcing the last one has a little bit of Hope but still compared to the impact of layer choice of layer it's ignorable so at this point we said okay well we can't locate the ethics no ethical knowledge at this project we're going to have to switch the direction and we end up doing a lot more in-depth analysis on
on this so in summary does localization help editing no the relationship is actually zero for this particular editing method that from what I know is pretty state-of-the-art and the counter of counter effect data it's not true are there any other editing methods that correlate better no but if somebody can answer this question for me that will be very satisfying like I feel like there should start something still be something there that we're missing but causal tracing I think what it does
is it reveals the factual information when the Transformer is passing forward I think it represents where's the fact when you're doing that but what we found here is that it has nothing to do with editing success those two things are different and we have to resolve that somehow but a lot of insights that they found in their paper is still useful like the early to mid-range NLP representation last token there they represent the factual something we didn't know before but it is important not to validate
localization methods using the editing method now we know and maybe not to motivate editing methods using via localization those are the two things now we know that we shouldn't do because we couldn't find a relationship any questions on this one before I move on to the next one you're not shocked by this I am shocked by this I'm still so puzzled like it should be there should be something I don't know all right so in summary of this first part we talked about why there the Gap might
exist and what she what machines know versus what we think machines now there are three hypothesis there are three ideas assumptions are wrong maybe our expectations are wrong maybe it's beyond us there's a good quote that says good at good artist still I think good researchers doubt we have to be really suspicious of everything that we do and that's maybe the biggest lesson that I've learned over many years that once you like your results so much that's a bad sign like come back like go home have a beer
go to sleep and next day you come back and like put your paper in on your desk and think okay now I'm gonna review this paper how do I criticize this one what do I not like about this paper right that's the one way to look at criticize your own research and and that will improve your thinking a lot so let's bring our attention back to our hopes and dreams it keeps coming back so here I came to realize maybe instead of just building tools to understand perhaps we need to do some groundwork what do I
mean well this alien that we've been dealing with trying to generate explanations seems to be a different kind so maybe we should study them as if they're like new species in the wild so what do you do when you observe a new species in the wild you have a couple ways but one of the ways is to observational study so you saw some species in the wild far away first you just kind of watch them you watch them and see what are they like what are their habitat how they what what do they what are their values and whatnot
and second way you can actually intervene and do a control study so we did something like this with reinforcement learning setup I'm going to talk about these two papers first paper emergent behaviors in multi-agent systems has been so cool who who saw this hide and seek video by open AI yeah it's so cool if you haven't seen it just Google it and watch it it's so fascinating I'm only covering the tip of an iceberg in this but at the end of this hide and seek episode at some point
the agents reveal a discover a bug in this physical system and start like anti-gravity flying in the air and like shooting hiders everywhere a super interesting video you must watch so lots of that and also humanoid football and capture the flag from deepmind lots of interesting behaviors emerging that we observed here's the my favorite one but but these labels so here these are labels that are provided by open AI running and chasing for building and ramp use but and these ones were that oh human or humans when
painstakingly one by one watch all these videos and label them manually so our question is can we is there better way to discover this emergent behaviors perhaps some nice visualization can help us explore this complex uh complex domain a little better so that's our goal so in this work we're going to again treat the agents like an observational study like us new species then we're going to do observational study and what that means is that we only get to observe State and action pair so where
they are what are they doing or uh yeah what are they doing and we're going to discover agent Behavior by basically kind of like a clustering the data that's all we're gonna do and how do we do it pretty simple a generative model have you have covered the Bayesian generator graphical no gotcha okay so think about hi then also what you teach yeah so this is a graphical model um think about this as a fake or hypothetical data generation process so how does this work like I'm generating
the data I created this system I'm going to first generate a joint latent embedding space for that represents all numbers that represents all the behaviors in the system and then I'm gonna for each agent I'm going to generate another embedding and each embedding when it's conditioned with State it's going to generate policy it's going to decide what it's going to do what action is given the state and the embedding pair and then what that whole thing generates is what you see the state and action
pair so how does this work well and then given this you build a model and you do inference to learn all these parameters kind of same business as neural network but it's just have a little more structure so this is completely made up right this is like my idea of how these new species might work and our goal is to we're going to try this and see if anything useful comes up and the way you do this is one of the ways you do this is you optimize for a variation lower bound you don't need to know that it's very cool
actually if if one gets into this exponential family business uh it's very cool CS 228 okay so here's one of the results that we had it's a domain called mujoko here we're going to pretend that we have two agents one controlling back leg and one controlling the front leg and on the right we're showing that joint embedding space Z Omega and z alpha while video is running I'm going to try to put the video back okay so now I'm going to select this is a visualization that we built or online
you can you can go check it out you can select a little space in agent one space and you see it maps to pretty tight space and Agent Zero and it shows pretty decent running ability so that's cool and now I'm going to select somewhere else in agent one that maps to kind of disperse area in Agent Zero it looks like it's not not doing as well and this is just an Insight that we gain for this data only but like I was quickly able to identify ah this type mapping business kind of represents the
good running behavior and bad running behaviors that's something that you can do pretty efficiently and now I'm going to show you something more interesting so of course we have to do this because we have the data it's it's here it's so cool so we apply this framework in the when ai's hide and seek this has four agent it looks like a simple game but it has pretty complex structure 100 dimensional observations uh five-dimensional action space so in this work remember that we pretend
that we don't know the labels given by open AI we just shuffle them in the mix but we can color them our results with respect to their labels so again this is the result of Z Omega and z alpha the individual agents but the coloring is something that we didn't know before we just did it after the fact you can see in the Z Omega there's nice kind of pattern that we can roughly separate what human what makes sense to humans and what makes sense to us but remember the the green and gray kind of
everywhere they're mixed so in this particular run of open AIS hide and seek it seemed that those two representations were kind of entangled the running and chasing the blue dots it seems to be pretty separate and distinguishable from all the other colors and that kind of makes sense because that's basis of playing this game so if you don't have that representation you have a you have a big trouble but in case of like orange which is fort building it's a lot more distinguishable in
hiders and that makes sense because hiders are the ones building the fort then Seekers don't build the fort so we're in just a little more entangled in Seekers perhaps if Seekers had built more separate for building uh representation maybe they would have win this game so this work can we learn something interesting emerging behaviors by just simply observing the system the answer seems to be yes at least for the domains that we tested a lot more more complex domains should be tested but these are
the ones we had but remember that these methods don't give you names of these clusters so you would have to go and investigate and click through and explore and if the cluster represents super superhuman concept this is not going to help you and I'll talk a little more about the work that that we do try to help them but this is not for you this is not going to help you there and also if you have access to the model and the reward signal you should use it why why dump it so next part we do use it I'm going to
talk about let's work with Nico and Natasha and Shay again so here this time we're going to intervene we're going to be a little intrusive but hopefully we'll learn a little more so problem is that we're going to build a new multi-agent system we're going to build it from scratch such that we can do control testing but at the same time we shouldn't sacrifice the performance so we're going to try to match the the performance of the overall system and we do succeed
I had this paper collaboration with Folks at Sanford actually here in 2020 where we propose this pretty simple idea which is you have on your own network why don't we embed Concepts in the middle of the bottleneck where one neuron represents three the other represents stripes and just train the model end to end and why are we doing this well because then at inference time you can actually intervene you can pretend you know predicting zebra I don't think three should matter so I'm gonna zero out this
neuron and feed forward and see what happens so it's particularly useful in the medical setting where there are some features that doctors don't want we can cancel on and test so this is the work to extend this to RL setting it's actually not as simple extension then as we thought it came out to be pretty complex but essentially we're doing that and we're building each of the concept bottleneck for each agent and at the end of the day what you optimize is what you usually do typical
PPO just think about this as make the make daughter system work plus minimizing the difference between the true concept and estimated concept that's all you do why are we doing this you can intervene you can pretend now agent 2 pretend that you can't see agent 1. what happens now that's what we're doing here we're going to do this in two domains first domain how many people looked at the uh saw this cooking game before yeah it's a it's a pretty commonly used cooking uh domain in reinforcement
learning very simple we have two agents yellow and blue and they're going to make soup they can bring Three Tomatoes they get a war they wait for the tomato and bring the dishes a dish to the cooking pot they get a reward finally their goal is to deliver as many soups as possible given given some time and here Concepts that we use are agent position orientation agent has tomato it has Dish etc etc something that's immediately available to you already and you can of course tweak the environment to make it more fun so you
can make it that they have to collaborate like you can build a wall between them so that they have to work together in order to serve any tomato soup or you can make them freely available you can work independently or together whatever your choice first uh just kind of send you the check was that you can you can detect the emerging behavior of coordination versus non-coordination so when the impassable environment when we made up that environment and suppose that RL system that we trained worked they were able to
deliver some soups then you see that when we intervene uh this graph let me explain this is a reward of an agent one when we when there's no intervention so this is perfectly good world and when there was an intervention this is the average value of intervening on all Concepts but I'm also going to show you each concept soon if you compare left and right you can tell that in the right when we intervene reward deteriorated quite a lot for both of them and that's one way to see yeah they are coordinating because somehow
intervening and at this concept impacted a lot of their performance but this is what what uh what was really interesting to me and I'm curious anyone can guess so this is the same graph as the one you saw before but except I'm plotting for intervention for each concept so I'm intervening team position team orientation team has tomato etc etc it turns out that they are using or rather when we intervene on team orientation the degradation of performance was the biggest to the extent that we believe that orientation
had to do with subcoordination does anyone can guess why this might be the position there's orientation yes just a clarification question on the orientation is that like the direction that the teammate is producing yes so it seems like orientation would let you yes yes that's right yes where were you when I was when I was pulling my hair hair over this question yes that's exactly right and initially I was really puzzled like why not position because I expect it to be positioned but exactly
that's exactly right so the orientation is the first signal that an agent can get about the next move over the other Asian because they're facing the pot they're going to the pot they're facing the Tomato they're going to get the tomato really interesting intuition but some too obvious to some but I needed this graph to work that out and of course you can use this to identify lazy agents if you look at the rightmost uh yellow agent our friend just chilling in the in the background
and he's lazy and if you train our religion there's always some agents just hanging out they just not do anything and you can you can easily identify this by using this graph if I intervene it it just doesn't impact any any of their Rewards so the second domain we're going to look at a little more complex domain so this is uh it's studying inter-agent social dynamics so in this domain there is a little bit of tension this is called a cleanup we have four agents they only get rewards if they eat apples just
yellow things or green things or apples uh but if you don't clean the river then Apple stops through all so somebody has to clean the river and you can see if there are four people trying to collect apples you can just stay someone else's to wait until someone else to to clean the river and then collect the apples and in fact that's sometimes what happens and Concepts here again are pretty uh pretty uh pretty common things position orientation and and pollution positions Etc so would we first plotted the same graph as
the previous domain it it it it tells a story so the story here is that when I intervene on Asian one it seems to influence Asian too quite a lot if you look at these three different uh graph reward how reward was impacted when I intervened on Asian one it's agent three and four are fine but it seems that only agent two is influenced same with idle time same with the Intel agent distance so we were like oh maybe that's true but we keep wondering there's like a lot going on in this domain like how do we know this is the
case so we decided to take another step so we're going to do a little more work here uh but but not a lot we're going to fill the graph to discover interagent relationships this is simplest dumbest way to build a graph but again I like simple things so how do you build a graph well suppose that you have you're building a graph between movies this is like not what we do but just to describe what we're trying to do we have each row if we want to build a matrix each row is a movie and each column consists of
features of these movies so length Jungle of the movie and so on and the simplest way to build a graph is to do a regression so exclude I I throw and then we're going to regress over everyone else and that gives me beta which is kind of coefficient for for each of these and that beta represents the strength between uh strengths of the edges so this movie is more related to this movie and not the other movie and ta-da you have a graph it's like dummy story there's a lot of caveats to you
shouldn't do this with them a lot of times but you know this is the simplest way to do it so we did the same thing here instead instead of movie we're going to use intervention on concept C on agent n as our node and for to build this Matrix we're going to use intervention outcome which wouldn't happen to be available without our framework for reward resource collected and and many other things and when you build this graph at the end of the day you get betas that represent relationship between these interventions
okay so I had a graph of that Matrix apparently I removed before I came over but imagine there was a matrix there is a nicely highlighted between agent 1 and 4 and that only contradicting the original hypothesis that we had and this is the video of it so when we stared at that Matrix it it turns out that there's no High Edge strong edges between agent one and two so we were like that's weird but there is strong edges between agent one and four so we like dig deeper into it watched a lot of uh a lot of sessions to
validate what's happening and it turns out that the story was a lot more complicated the ones orientation was important for four but when that fails agent 1 and 2 kinda gets cornered in and you can see that in the graph agent 4 kind of get a get agent one and four uh sorry one and two blue and yellow agent kind of gets in the corner together they kind of get stuck and this is simply just accidental because of the way that we built this environment it just happened but but the true the raw statistics
wouldn't have told us this story that this was completely accidental in fact there was no correlation no coordination between agent one and two but only after the graph we realized this was the case now this might be one-off case but you know what a lot of emerging behaviors that we want to detect a lot of them will be one-off case and we really want to get to the truth of that rather than having some surface level statistics so can we build multi-agent system that enables intervention and performs as
well the answer is yes there's a graph that shows the red line and blue line roughly a line that's good news we are performing as well um but remember these Concepts you need to label them or you should have some way of getting those Concepts positions and orientation there might be something that we would love to extend in the future before I go on any questions you shy [Music] cool all right so I did tell you that we're not gonna know uh move uh the solution to move 37 I still don't okay I still don't
but I'll tell you a little bit of work that I'm currently doing I'm really excited about uh that we started thinking you know what will this understanding move 37 happen before within my lifetime and I was like oh maybe not but I kind of want it to happen so we start this is all about research right you started carving out a space where things are a little resolvable and you try to attack that problem so this is our attempt to do exactly that to get a little closer to our ultimate goal or my ultimate goal of
understanding that move 37. so before that how many people here know Alpha Zero from T my yes Alpha zero is a self-trained uh self-trained chess playing machine that beats that has higher yellow rating than any other humans and beats stockfish which is arguably no existing human can beat stock fish so in the previous paper we try to discover human chess Concepts in this network so when does concept like material imbalance appear in its Network which layer and when in the training time and which we call what when and where
plots and we also compare the evolution of opening moves between humans and Alpha zero these are the first couple moves that you make when you play chess and as you can see there's a pretty huge difference left is human right is Alpha zero it turns out that Alpha zero can master or supposedly Master a lot of variety of different types of openings openings can be very aggressive openings can be very boring could be very long range targeting for long range strategy or short range very different so that
begs a question what does alpha zero know that humans don't know don't you want to learn what that might be so that's what we're doing right now we're actually almost um we're about to about to evaluate so the goal of this war is please teach the world chess champion on new chess superhuman chess strategy and we just got yes from Magnus Carlson who is the world chess champion he just lost the match I know but but you know he still he's still champion in my mind he's still championed in two
categories actually so the way that we're doing this is we're going to discover new chess strategy by explicitly explicitly for getting existing chess strategy which we have a lot of data for and then we're going to learn a graph this time a little more complicated graph by uh using the the existing relationships between existing Concepts so that we can get a little bit of more idea of what the New Concept might look like and Magnus Carlson uh so my favorite part about this work I talk about
carving out my favorite part about this work is that the evaluation is going to be pretty clear so it's not just like Magnus coming in inside say oh your work is kind of nice and and say nice things about our work no Magnus actually has to solve some puzzles and we will be able to evaluate him whether he did it or not so it's like a kind of success and fail but I'm extremely excited this kind of work I can only do because of Lisa who is a champion herself but also a PhD student at Oxford and like she played against
Magnus in the past and many others chestplates in the world and she's going to be the ultimate uh pre-super human filtering to filter out these Concepts that will eventually get to Magnus so I'm super excited about this I have no results but it's coming up I'm excited yes generator because it's already so many puzzles out there so I'm assuming that there's probably something new what are the problems puzzles are actually pretty simple so the way that we generate concepts are
within the embedding space of alpha zero and given that because Alpha zero has really weird architecture so every single latent layer in Alpha zero has the exact same position as a chessboard that's just the way that they decide to do it so because of that we can actually identify or generate the board positions that corresponds to that concept and because we have MCTS we can predict what move it's going to make given that board position because at inference time it's actually deterministic of the whole lot
plus zero thing so these we have a lot of board positions and that's all you need for puzzles you give up board position and then ask Magnus to make a move we explain the concept and then give Magnus more board positions and see if we can apply that concept that he just learned for example right but it seems like you're kind of underneath yeah so the if I were to ask stockfish to solve those puzzles that were a different question because we're interested in whether we can teach human
not stockfish stockfish might be able to do that's actually interesting uh thing that we could do now I think about but our goal is to just teach one superhume like if I have for example 10 000 superhuman Concepts and only three of them are digestible by Magnus that's a win that would be a big win for for this type of research questions all right yeah so oh so wrap up small steps towards our hopes and dreams we talked about the gap between What machines know versus what we think machines know three ideas why that might
be true the three different maybe angles we can try to attack and answer those questions and the the bridge that Gap we talked about studying aliens these machines in observation study or control study there are many other ways to study your species uh and I'm not an expert but anthropology and other Humanity studies would know a lot better more about this and maybe just maybe we can try to understand move 37 at some point hopefully within my lifetime through this chess uh project that I'm very
excited about thank you [Applause] you talked about interprecility research that costs NLP vision and RL um do you think there's much about first taking certain interpretability techniques from one modality into other modalities all right so it depends on your goal I think like think about fairness research which uh Builds on strong mathematical foundation and that's like applicable for any questions around fairness or hopefully applicable but then once you if your goal is to actually solve a fairness
issue at hand for somebody the real person in the world that's completely different question you would have to customize it for a particular application so there are two venues and I think similar is true interoperability like the theory work that I talked about shop and IG are used across domains like Vision texts so that theory paper would be applicable across the domain things like RL and the way that we build that generative model you would need to test a little bit more to make sure that this
works in NLP uh I don't even know how to think about agents in NLP yet so it will need a little bit of tweaking but both directions are fruitful John has a question I saw the recent work in which some amateur go players found a very tricky strategy to trick up I think it was alphago and that seemed like a concept that humans know that machines don't in that Venn diagrams about that yeah actually it's funny you mentioned that Lisa can beat Alpha zero pretty easily and it's a similar idea because uh if you you kind
of know what are the most unseen out of distribution moves are and and he she can break Alpha zero pretty easily at least I guess that if Isa Dole had known something more about AI then maybe he would have tried to confuse alphago but the truth is you know it takes a lot it's a high stake game like he said oh it's like a the famous star worldwide so he wouldn't want to make a a move that would be seen as a complete mistake like the one that Magnus made couple of days ago that got on the news feed everywhere
that he made this Taco century-wide mistake and that's that's probably hurts any other questions zero for example I just like building machine learning lazy's games really well um well these work that I've presented are pretty you um but there has been a bit of discussion in in the robotics applying potentially these two Robotics and of course I can't talk about details but um uh things that reinforcement learning in the wild people worry about or some of the surprises right if you have a test for
it like if you have a unit test for it you're never going to fail because you're going to test before you deploy I think the biggest risk for any of this deployment systems is the surprises that you didn't expect so my work around the visualization and others aim to help you with that so we may not know names of these surprises but here's a tool that help you better discover those surprises before someone else does or someone else gets harm um this is kind of an open independent
question but I was wondering we're talking about a lot of ways in which we try to kind of visualize or understand what's going on in the representation inside the machine but I was wondering whether we could turn it around and try to teach machines to tell us like what using our language is what they're doing and their representations like illegal representations of ours and then get the machine to do the translation for us instead of us going into the English yeah great question so it's a really
interesting question because um that's something that I kind of tried in in my work previous work called testing with Concept activation vectors so that was to map human language into machine space so that they can only speak our language because I understand my language and just talk to me in my language the challenge is that how would you do that for something like Alpha zero like we don't have a vocabulary for it like move 37 then there's going to be a lot of missing valuable knowledge that
we might we might not get from the machine so I think the approach has to be both ways we should leverage as much as we can but acknowledging that even that mapping that trying to map our language to machines is going to is not going to be perfect because it's a kind of proxy for what we think like a penguin is there's a psychology research that says everyone thinks very differently about what penguin is like if I like a picture of penguin everyone was thinking different penguin right now
right Australia has the cutest penguin the fairy penguin I'm thinking that right I don't know how many people are thinking that so given that like we give we're so different machine's gonna think something else so how do you bridge that Gap extend that to 100 Concepts and composing those Concepts it's gonna go out a while very soon so there's pros and cons I'm into both of them I think some applications exclusively exclusively just using human concepts are still very helpful it gets
you uh halfway but my ambition is that we shouldn't stop there we should benefit from them by having us having them teach us new things that we didn't know before but like um I don't know but like trying to locate like specific strategies in the embedding space What are the alternatives I guess I don't know the Alternatives just because I feel like the wrong thing that's possible so like it's like some transformed space of our embedding space in Alpha zero maybe it's a function of
uh applied to that embedding space so thinking about that as a raw Vector is is a is a dead end could be uh we'll see how this chess project goes in a couple months I might I might rethink my strategy but interesting thought yeah so I'm a Psychology major and I do realize that a lot of the stuff will be trying to hear like at least this is how we can figure out how our brains work and so I think that this would there be um stuff that um use that's applicable to internal networks and on the contrary
youth English means interpretability it's in the studies of neural network will help us understand and stuff for our own brain yeah I talked to Jeffrey Hinton uh you know he would really like this so I believe I believe you probably know about this history I think that's how it all started right the whole neural network is to understand human brain um so so that that that's that's the answer to your question interesting however in my view there is some biases that we have in neuros Neuroscience because of
the limitations of tools like physical tools and availability of humans that you can poke in I think that influences interpretability research and I'll try to give you an example what I mean so in you know cat near the the line or the horizontal line and vertical line neuron in cat brain so they put the prop in and figure out this one neuron detects vertical lines and you can like validate it's really cool if you look at the video the video is still online yeah what is it yes yes yes uh so why why did they do
that well because you had one cat and a four poor cat and you had uh we can only prob a few neurons at a time right so that that implied a lot of few interpreportable research actually looked at or very focused on like neuron wise representation like this one neuron must be very special I actually think that's not true that was limited by our ability like physical ability ability to prop organisms but in your network you don't have to do that like you can apply functions to embeddings you can change
the whole embedding to something else override so that kind of uh is actually a uh obstacle in our thinking rather than helping yeah okay maybe we should call it there um so for Thursday when you're not having uh lecture on Thursday um there'll be Tas in me here so if you have any you know last minute panics on your project so I think we might have some straight inside to help you we probably won't actually um final lecture cs224 in today [Applause]